this was Lucy letby's last day on the
witness stand during which the
prosecution called the former neonatal
nurse a liar and a murderer the court
was told about social media searches
that Miss letby had done whilst on shift
at the Countess of Chester Hospital on
one occasion searching in quick
succession for the families of three
different babies she's alleged to have
harmed
the prosecution Barrister Nick Johnson
Casey said what was the connection in
your mind between those three people
they are babies who have died from being
seriously unwell Lucy letby replied Nick
Johnson said you were checking up on
your victims weren't you no the nurse
replied you are a killer who was looking
at your victims no
over 14 days Lucy letby gave evidence
answered questions and vigorously denied
all of the charges against her and over
that time the court has also been shown
text messages that the nurse sent to
colleagues saying that the ward they
worked on was understaffed and unsafe
she was also suggested to the
prosecution that raw sewage had gone on
to one of the nursery wards where babies
were being cared for and there was also
the suggestion from the prosecution
about a possible motive they say that
Lucy letby killed babies to attract the
attention and sympathy of a male
colleague on whom she had a crush
charges she vigorously again denies
today Lucy letby denied having an affair
with that same colleague who was married
but she agreed she did have an active
social life going out drinking with
former colleagues after her suspension
from the ward in 2016. it was a period
of time during which the prosecution
said she'd previously told the court her
mental health had deteriorated she was
isolated from colleagues and very alone
Nick Johnson KC said you are a very
calculating woman aren't you Lucy letby
no you tell lies deliberately don't you
no the reason you tell lies is to try to
get sympathy from people no to get
attention no
the court was also shown once more a
note written by Miss letby and found at
her home in which she says I am evil I
did this
this is how I felt at that time Lucy
letby said I could not see a future for
myself Nick Johnson replied you are a
murderer no I am not you have murdered
many children I've never murdered a
child or harmed any of them
in her final moments on the stand Lucy
letby told the court before all this had
happened before her arrests she'd had a
very happy life
the trial continues next week Catherine
avatotsi Sky News Manchester